we were a team despite our differences
and in spite of the terrible things
they've done we were still a team that's
not how the higher-ups oughta know the
guys upstairs but they're perfectly
pressed shirts for them we were judged
by our level of expendability and they
knew that our next mission was the death
sentence one by one that thing took out
my team my friends snapping their necks
so quickly and with such ease that no
sooner did I hear the scream they were
dead
we had been used I'd been used delivered
us pray to the predator a plot that was
sanctioned by the bosses and approved
with a blood-red stamp
why did they do it I'm still trying to
figure that out maybe that's something
you can tell me after you hear how these
so-called scientific men left us in the
cell and in the hands of scp-173
for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times the
best because I'd quickly risen through
the ranks of the facility
the worst because well I'll get denied I
was never the best student I finished
high school by the skin of my teeth and
my job prospects looked bleak but I was
lucky I guess or at least had thought so
at the time you see I have an uncle
Siegfried who did some work for the
government I never actually knew what he
did just that it was secretive work I
used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
I was when he found out I needed a job
and he offered to help me out I couldn't
believe it I always thought he hated me
I had overheard him telling my parents
that I was a no-good deadbeat but now he
had a change of heart he's willing to
take me under his wing but what I get to
do undercover intelligence gathering
international assassinations just you
wait he said and that's how I found
myself walking into a sprawling
futuristic looking facility where they
handed me a level one security clearance
card with big bold letters that read
janitor but I was happy just the words
security clearance made me feel
important and it beat flipping burgers
I pushed mops turned off lights fired up
generators clocked in and clocked out
but all that time they must have been
washing me grooming me waiting for the
day they could throw me to the wolves I
should have known
I've always been an expendable kind of
guy after a few years I was called to an
office there was a man in a plaid shirt
and kind of a tweed jacket that
professors were he asked me do you have
any idea about what we actually do here
and to be honest I didn't I knew that
there were many parts of the facility
I couldn't enter I imagine that down a
maze of corridors with weapons being
felt prisoners being interrogated but I
had no idea about the anomalies how
could I
before I was told anything I had to sign
a bunch of forms or so many I thought
I'd get to find out who really killed
JFK and while they didn't come out and
say it what I inferred was that if I
ever talk about what happens at the
facility to someone outside the facility
well let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves padded cells and
the rusty tools I wasn't scared though I
was part of something big something
secret and I loved it so I signed my
life away with no hesitation soon after
I was introduced to my first anomaly the
safe class of course they took me to an
observation room from that room I could
see into another room with a sign on the
wall that read SCP 0 6 7 and just stood
there waiting for something to happen
when in walked another guy in a white
lab coat welcome to your first anomaly
you so is it ok if i hook you up to this
heart monitor we want to gauge your
reaction to what you see all I can see I
told them is an empty room with a table
what looks like a pen on top of some
papers correct he said half smiling as
if I was some kind of idiot
that's scp-060 I thought about telling
him that if I needed years of training
before I could see a pen that I probably
should have taken that fast-food job
could have been a shift manager by now
then they brought a young chimpanzee
into the room small enough to be
harmless one of the guys forced a pen
into the scared ships hand and something
strange happened it started scribbling
nonsense at first but suddenly it was
sketching and drawing faster and faster
I could catch glimpses of words and
images by the time they dragged it out
it was flying
around like it was possessed that pen is
power to the man in the lab code a power
whose source our origin we don't fully
understand that's why we're here that's
why you are here one of the guys in the
other room held the chimps drawing up to
the window it was a perfect sketch of
the Tower of London intricate and
brilliant above the sketch was the title
Tower of London Tudor period circa 1541
the Year Margaret Pohl the Countess of
Salisbury lost her head on the chopping
block underneath that the chimp had
written pity she was no traitor take it
from me I was there they didn't need to
look at the heart rate monitor to see
that I was shocked that was far from the
only anomaly I had come into contact
with and I must have been doing
something right
because in time I went from level one to
two to level three security clearance
and that's when they made me a
containment specialist I won't bore you
with all the details but as you can
guess I dealt with the containment of
anomalies a lot of my time was spent
looking through small windows and cell
doors making sure that whatever was
inside was still inside and it's still
in one piece other times I worked with
field agents when anomalies were brought
in a transition period that the arrested
freaks didn't much like there was one
certain anomaly though but I was tasked
to oversee on many occasions I like to
think of it as my pet but in hindsight I
was its pet this was scp-173 something
that was in what we call the euclid
class classification meaning that we
don't fully understand it but no it is
very dangerous
we know it's intelligent we know it's
unpredictable and we know it will kill
and for that reason there's people
tasked with containing it and keeping an
eye on it at all times at first glance
you wouldn't guess just how dangerous
173 is you wouldn't think it's
incredibly intelligent in fact you'd
think the opposite that's because it's
more or less a walking slab of concrete
and rebar with stunted limbs and traces
of spray-paint that give the impression
of a dopey face we have to enter it sell
twice a week for cleaning duties it
leaves the disgusting foul-smelling
liquid on the floor a reddish-brown
substance that I can only
described as a mix of blood and waste
products where that stuff comes from has
remained a mystery since we first
contained it in 1993 going into the cell
was always a three-man job
because and this is maybe the weirdest
part about 173 it can't move if human
eyes are watching it that's why you need
at least two people watching it at all
times if you were in the room watching
173 by yourself and blinked you'd be
dead before your eyes open we don't know
how it moves that fast but in that
fraction of a second your neck is
snapped so hard it's almost like being
decapitated I've seen the videos to
prove it all it took was a sneeze
he wasn't even finished getting the rest
of the achoo out when there was a flash
and his partner was left lying on the
ground his head twisted around the wrong
direction so you can understand why we
now require three men for any time we
must enter 173 South then a few months
ago I was told that a long process would
begin to train and re-educate some
future class T's Class T's are mostly
prisoners with life long sentences or
those we've taken from death row and
given a new lease on life
we were apparently understaffed so why
not employ these men whose lives had
pretty much ended anyway that was the
rationale or at least that's what they
told me I was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173 mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
specialist could focus on more important
tasks they hadn't been through the
training I had seen what I had seen but
after showing them the video 173 nearly
taking off a man's head they were more
than willing to follow the rules they
understood not to blink or turn away or
sneeze and that any lapse in focus could
lead to a violent death so I started to
show them the ropes shall we move as a
team into the cell and always keep the
others informed on what we're doing
173 was always sitting in the corner of
a cell no expression on that crude face
but when we walked in itself I got the
feeling it knew something had changed I
felt almost as if it was communicating
with me
but I couldn't tell what I was trying to
say and it happened it was a Tuesday
afternoon three days from the last time
we cleaned as usual 173 had covered the
floor with that horrible liquid we
headed in to clean my new team alert us
always and some of them cleaned while
others kept their eyes focused on the
thing in the corner things were going
smoothly when we heard him noise I knew
very well it was the sound of the cell
door locking someone must have screwed
up hey guys were locked in here I shot
it through the intercom nothing guys the
damn doors locked
nothing I lost it a bit
open the door will you nothing my team
looked at me the ones not on eye contact
duty that is as if I should know what to
do hoping that this had happened before
and that there was some kind of standard
plan to deal with it there wasn't
we were always observed when in the room
and I knew that a technician couldn't
accidentally lock the door it was
impossible
there were protocols someone had done
this on purpose the four of us sat in
the corner of the room as far from 173
as possible our eyes locked on it it
didn't move an inch as usual just stood
staring at the wall as it always did we
stayed awake through the night talking a
little bit holding on to the slim hope
that something had gone wrong but as
night turned today again we all began to
lose hope we weren't sent here to clean
we were a test totally expendable lab
rats but I wouldn't go down without a
fight we couldn't just stay up forever
that was a death sentence I suggested
that two of us stand one sit and rest
and one get some sleep we take shifts a
couple hours on couple hours off maybe
we could show that we wouldn't give up
and have time to realize what they were
doing was insane call off the test and
come free us we made it through a couple
of shifts like this and it seemed like
we'd actually be able to make it another
day or two when
things went wrong it was my turn to sit
and rest when I heard the worst possible
noise snoring the con next to me was
sleeping quietly so it must be one of
the Stander's I glanced over for just a
split second and sobbed both of them
leaning against the cell wall dozing at
the same time I saw the flash crack snap
pop one after another their necks were
snapped I'm not sure how it happened but
I was standing again staring at 173 who
was now in the corner dead bodies with
their heads twisted around piled up in
front then I couldn't take it anymore
I couldn't stare at this thing forever I
felt myself giving up I lowered my head
to the ground and then finally broke my
gaze ready to die and then nothing
happened I slowly raised my head back up
and there it was it's hideous face
inches away from mine it was then that I
understood what we've been containing
what we'd underestimated I felt it again
like it was telling me something was
telling me to close my eyes to sleep so
I did but as my eyes closed I didn't see
darkness I saw 173 or something like it
but not in the cell I saw it outside in
the world standing over children
sleeping in the beds watching I saw them
hiding in the shadows staring out at
passers-by and I realized they weren't
watching waiting to pounce no they were
hiding my eyes popped open as the door
opened an inrush six security personnel
they took me outside jab my leg with a
syringe injecting me with something as
the world faded away
incident report time and date redacted
following the experimental forced
interaction with Euclid class anomaly
scp-173 subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire days
sitting in corner of cells staring at
the wall staff are advised to proceed
with caution when dealing with subject
as the only behavior they engage in is
an attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever this report has been read
and approved by redacted redacted and
dr. Siegfried Schwarz